you're wearing a spider oh my god
perfect hello Greg Sony Fox yeah Kyle
either men from fan 30p go check out his
youtube channel please desperation is
the most attractive quality you got a
pair hose we are gonna watch the Morbius
trailer breakdown spider-man Easter eggs
in details from new rock stars because
they are very comics knowledgeable John
I we did a reaction review for the
trailer of course it's more movie
centric but I love these guys because
they really know their comic I don't
know Morbius from the comics all that
well they're also very fast and keep
your attention very well so many a lady
have told me the same thing Kyle that's
a lie they said hurry up get it over
with
in a consensual wow this is going off
the rails welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Erik Bosse in the I'm excited about
it Kyle's not
well I've known you since you were a
child
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
am I reading too much
the spider-man 2 the spider-man 2 good
further his desperation to finding a
cure for this terminal illness Studio
title cards include these specific
wording in association with problems to
the New Deal linked between Disney and
Sony last year world studios will
continue to consult on Sony Marvel
properties and Morpheus them does not
firmly make them part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe would be but but but
Bulger and but but but but
I'm coming far from home says those are
jointly Sony credit scenes Paulin
himself as two movies left on this
contract at spider-man one of which will
be a third spider-man movie communites
enter 2021 crash 6 being another unnamed
MCU team-up film in the future how goes
the theory that passed that back Daniel
ventures in designed by Disney to flood
their studio with enough from licensing
the spider-man character / merchandise
and other things so that in maybe three
or four years they could be able to buy
[Music]
[Music]
because in the early yeah seems just
like a hero
Batman beginner
Jeremy worry about the blood of the
vampire bats
[Music]
surprise sponsor every can of bang makes
a contribution to the Trump campaign
that's why I drink rain which is pretty
much exactly the same it's nice to see
someone who's not an Instagram model but
it is not a
it's a grand model doing a bang promo I
don't look at its grand level
okay this trailer now switches them to
early 2000 superhero movie mode as more
ways feels the effectiveness
self-treatment breaking the glass of a
containment cell and rising to a speech
without use of crutches or of these
effects in the next
[Music]
in all fairness Jared Leto's body
Nashville just does look that way not
like he did that for this role probably
CG is my grass in word concentration
perhaps you're trying to calculate how
much of a bullet concentration is
digestive tract to stay alive presumably
he wants to attack with few people as
possible
gratuitous before and after shot of Leto
that is poor when the lighting was an
unflattering fluorescent diffusion
switch to a people who don't have his
body looks like science
[Applause]
here Morbius parcours straight out of
x-men - the DNA has created a cake that
I can buy there's a lot of comics for me
to conduct experiment and then is
rescued by the groom in another road
when the attacks and kills here are the
next big skip attack something that's
broke
[Music]
Tyrese Gibson CIA agent Simon strap who
in the comics was agent tasked with
hunting down lobbyists other animals he
was a man that's man goes by crown and
later eager he is more B's friend who
suffers from these things where to point
these a negative top this body of
another figure the comics Morbius
accidentally kills his friend Niko's
plagues it with kills from their forward
no that's tooms is wearing the same
white jumpsuit suggesting that maybe he
crossed paths when they're both bars at
the moment is Mac Gargan scorpion who
swore revenge on spider-man as well as
Queen is we also know that Kraven the
hunter may also be bored this story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
new Q&A series the big question which
spill when I give you too much
information how we messed up these
Marvel characters are when you apply
real world history to nice very well
done very well done and another very
very fantastic breakdown from new rock
stars first off I know they moved
Studios recently yeah and the camera
quality of their videos of when he's
just talking to camera loose great too
sharper than before I'm also loving how
he's always been self-aware but it seems
exceptionally more self-aware now
whenever it seems like he's really
reaching yeah like did they really have
the blood trickled down to the pie how
many retakes it they do on that it's not
doing it it's not doing it digital it in
post screw this this is taking too long
yeah and they really focused on it for a
while the joke at the end mater were the
people are making fun of a like the
marvel body shot is me mean it of itself
I make fun of a tube but I've seen
photos of Jared Leto and ceramic or this
movie it was even filming and I'm like
that's how Jared Leto's body looks no he
he just say he's in great shape it's
like if Ryan Reynolds is ripped you know
and does Jared Leto he's ripped you know
exact he stays in great shape unless he
has to gain weight for a role or he get
too skinny for that being said though
there are things they talked about that
I briefly touched on in our trailer
review cuz I didn't see any set photos
of this my only familiarity with Morbius
comes from the 90s cartoon show where he
was introduced in the neo genex
storyline where it does go into Peter
Parker's mutating into like an actual a
the six arms I wanted to bring that up
and forgot to is I'm kind of hoping when
Tom Holland continues with these
he's not spider-man 3 but I think it'd
be cool to get some like weird body
horror thing that does tie it all in I
think if it does happen it'll happen
probably outside of the direct MCU oh no
it wouldn't at all but yeah I think when
they're dealing with you know the blood
and the mutating and all these is sure
it will work the one thing I thought
they might have brought up that dawned
on me is this trope of spider-man
villains I know Eddie Brock doesn't
qualify for this but characters who know
spider-man doesn't seem like Michael
Morbius knows who spider-man is but
tends to do science experiments that go
wrong to try to cure something right and
yeah that is definitely what the
majority of his villains do yeah like
Doc Ock even Connors and as the lizard
yeah even the original vulture from the
comics was like that they chanced him a
little bit for the movie but yeah I
didn't know what Jared Leto's take on
Michael Morbius was gonna because I was
aware that and the cartoon show
he had like a Transylvanian accent he's
from Greece yes supposed to look a
little bit unattractive because of his
blood disease luckily Romanian yeah and
then he shows up here needs a ha still a
hot American dude from thirty Seconds to
Mars I thought because it's Jared Leto
he might have pushed to do something a
little bit more like that but maybe they
were like whoa what you did with the
Joker you went too far with that man we
got a dial back here a little bit I
think Sony also has a lot to do with
that to be honest yeah probably
Eddie Brock is cool hipster guy this
breakdown seemed to be a primarily focus
on how a plot might unfold
yeah with Matt Smith's character and
even with Jared Harris's character him
might potentially killing him I'm glad
they brought up the reference points of
how a lot of this does seem like a 8
imagery from like I got venom vibes I
got Batman Begins vibes a lot of
Nightcrawler vibes definitely while
there's things I'm actually looking
forward to my main concern was what is
its own unique personality that it's
gonna have and there's plenty to cutting
back for an MCU and then venom because
it's like this seems the Sony antihero
verse has this like blue
aesthetic the MCU has been criticized in
the past for a lot of its films before
having a similar looking palette and it
seems like the Sony films have decided
on the sound of Marvel characters yeah
yeah I know you're not super excited for
it I'm not not excited for it like I
like Morbius as a character I mean I
like blade more because they're both
kind of similar but I hope it does well
and I hope that that Sony and Disney can
like make something work that doesn't
make me want to blow but whenever Sony
messes up they really mess up true and
so I'm not really looking for a bomb to
explode on everyone when it finally does
and so I think I'm just like living in
this dread every time they keep putting
out more stuff I did like venom I don't
think it was on par with the quality I
think I think venom was cool in terms of
the casting and in terms of the visual
effects yeah it was a lot of fun I had
the thought to of are they somehow
building to their own insidious or
sinister six they are they've been doing
this whole time but would I be excited
to watch because they're not real
villains and this world that they're
building right culture is right but this
isn't Joker so they can't I mean that's
what I mean venom is totally a hero in
his own movie
Morbius looks like you can have we
haven't seen the movie so for all I know
they're gonna really surprise me here
it's Sony he's gonna be here I'm Matt
Smith will be the bad guy right right to
me I'm like whoa this is gonna feel like
heroes fighting spider-man what are they
gonna get along in the end or something
like there are half of them if they do
have Mysterio and Volturi part of the
team that's kind of where my trepidation
comes with them all gearing up to fight
spider-man in one movie if that is what
they're building Carson I just I think
Sony only builds up they don't really
focus on how to naturally get there I
think they just like to produce things
they know that they can keep their
franchise going and that that you're
giving people technically what they want
but they're not necessarily going to do
it in the most natural way
cuz nothing I mean I thought venom did
its own thing for that I did its own
thing but it seems like when they
renewed their contract they were like so
we compete revolt right now and we
directly reference spider-man maybe we
could build up to all these things now
you know yeah I mean there's still yeah
there's still something that they're
working towards and they've been wanting
to do a sinister six going all the way
back to tell them yourself yeah how do
we get it it may not be exactly who we
wanted but we'll work with it and what
can happen
I'm surprised new rock stars in touch on
the possible theory I think it would be
cool now that they have into the spider
verse which I visit a steer edible which
Sony did I know I was bitter about it
but I loved it he's good how do they
have the the route and and Marvel in
general is open up the multiverse thing
yeah and the fact that spider-man's
outfit where it's an murderer on it was
the Tobey Maguire spider-man right
outfit I've been thinking it would be
cool to get some movie were they have
like Andrew Garfield Tony Maguire and
Tom Hall and all live actions appearing
together cuz that hasn't been done
before I think that'd be so freakin
awesome to do I'm not gonna lie I think
that'd be kind of awesome too
ok so cool and the fact that they had a
Tobey Maguire outfit made me kind of go
there yeah they're references though
that they brought up with San Francisco
all I'm gonna see in the trailer is the
murderer with the spider-man outfit I
wasn't even happy I caught that yeah but
the Zodiac killer the fact that venom is
in San Francisco it makes me think that
Sony's really trying to like set this in
a different City so that that way in
case it does happen they can still say
it's part of the MCU spider-man's on the
run he's moved to California personally
I would prefer if they're gonna do some
kind of like dimensional jumping that
they use the Madame Madame web yeah they
are working on that too which they are
yeah it seems like they do have some
type of plan in mind
sure now the question is what other
standalone vegan because as much as I
thought venom was a lot of fun I think
Morbius needs to be a better film then
what venom gave us in venom two might be
better because of who's directing it you
never know
but Morbius I will say this trailer
impressed me I just got really irritated
with that last bit I did not want to see
Michael Keaton in this universe I was
like okay so it's a different you
michael keaton well the fact they're
pulling vulture into here right does
affect continuity timeline in a way sure
for whatever spider-man three could
potentially be because like they pointed
out here the last time I saw vulture he
was in prison and now he is out of
prison so they've indirectly affected
the storyline of vulture in the MCU now
that he's out so if they ever want to
put vulture in the next spider-man movie
they have to work with what Sony did
honestly I don't think Marvel's going to
work with do you think they consulted
marble I don't think they did what we
saw the trailer I think there was
something in the new contract that they
signed that basically allowed them to
get away with it without even asking
permission I mean granted it is their
property they have every right to do
what they want with spider-man yeah
that's absolutely true and and I have no
problem with them building a whole new
spider-man like I'm totally fine with
that
just leave the MCU do what you want or
like I suggested like just do the
dimensional hopping and that way we can
justify why these are so totally
different universe fair enough fair
enough
and the Raimi's spider-man version which
had JK Simmons it's j jonah Jameson yes
they introduced J jonah Jameson son and
spider-man two in that movie and then
they have venom in spider-man 3 but the
whole linkage between j jonah Jameson's
son going into space with the symbiote
that wasn't ever explored so now that j
jonah Jameson was imminent that way yes
back in the MCU or the Sony whatever the
hell were calling this now they can
maybe do the thing new rock star to say
you know maybe maybe as I said I like to
think that we're gonna have similar
characters played by the same actors in
both universes but they're different
universes because yeah there's no way
that venom is actually in the same
universe as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's just like they're clearly
not connected in any way they can't be
they might be they might just not have
mentioned Thor
that's where Heaven Feige and you zoom
in on his face and all right guys well I
still really love this video for new
rock stars
yeah breakdown fun speculation guys
subscribe to them
very detailed you can do the same thing
for us if you so desire kyle fan theory
TV go check him out and i like to end
this with a couple of patron of the day
shoutouts one to a man named andrew
Nickerson and another man named Josh
both of you guys have not talked to me
in a while
you both have pledged and I appreciate
the pledged pledges are great but Josh
Andrew Nickerson guys where have you
been you know I like to the to do the
communicating with one another maybe
what you gotta do I got a suggestion
Andrew I think you should cut open your
hand let it form the PI symbol and Josh
knowing how he is will gravitate towards
you and then both of you will find your
way to a computer to talk with me guys
send a message to Greg he's seriously
honest and hardworking and he will
absolutely reach back I agree with
one-third of those